on commence non et elle
théâtre musique danse cirque les arts de
la scène revisité par l'esprit de la
commedia sont à l'honneur tout le mois
de juin à versailles dans le cadre du
mois molière plus de 300 spectacles
investissent la cité royale des lieux
phares tels les grandes et petites
écuries du château ou plus insolites
comme les parcs places et jardins
redonne au théâtre populaire toutes ses
lettres de noblesse
le mois molière 2013 et sous le signe de
la création à l'instar de viva la
commedia compagnies en résidence à
versailles qui rejoindra ensuite les
planches du festival off d'avignon qui
te créations sont joués ici et c'est
notre avant-postes du festival d'avignon
dont on fait ce second festival et on a
à versailles un public qui est qui est
très agréable car il a une part
d'exigences et en même temps d'accueil
très qui était généreux et ouvert donc
on a bon baromètre de ce qui va se
passer avignon
cherchez plutôt un objet qu'ils rentrent
à la
plusieurs nouveautés sont au programme
la tragédie fera ses premiers pas dans
le festival avec antigone de sophocle le
hip-hop et le beatbox rencontreront la
commedia dell'arte et enfin un nouveau
lieu de représentation sera inaugurée en
la chapelle auch pour 3 lecture inédite
essentiellement en entrée libre cette
18e édition démontre à nouveau
l'engagement du festival pour le
développement d'un renouveau des arts de
la scène accessible à tous